if you've been waiting for any release
date info for the next installment of
God of War I've got good news
maybe I'm Tony and this is your possibly
leaked GameSpot news update as spotted
by Twitter's favorite news dude Wario 64
the God of War ps4 release date was
listed as March 22nd 2018 on the
PlayStation Store other than this being
a Thursday it seems like a realistic
launch date and I do personally think
we'll see the game released pretty early
next year
however the store listing has since been
changed and it now reads December 31st
2018 a placeholder date signifying an
intended launch day sometime next year
so maybe someone flipped a switch too
soon PlayStation experience is happening
this week after all as for the game
itself god of war takes place after the
original trilogy and trades the country
of Greece for a Nordic setting director
Corey Barr log says the game is quote
open but it's not a fully open-world
adventure we'll have to wait and see and
as far as 2017 games keep an eye on
GameSpot as we countdown our game of the
year over the next few weeks
you